[Applause]
with each passing day coronavirus cases
are rising
and at the fastest rate of infection
anywhere in the world
thousands of people have died so far
the fatality rate may be low compared to
the population
but the trajectory of the virus is on an
upward trend
with no signs of it relenting
the psy hospital in mumbai has been on
the forefront of this battle
it caters to people living in dharavi
asia's
largest slum close to 700 000
live in a 1.5 square mile space
a perfect fertile ground for a pandemic
it's such a big slum and so many people
10 to 15 people living together so
social distancing is not possible
india's poor have been the worst
affected
in jharkhand one of the poorest states
in the country
this public health care is overburdened
in normal circumstances
in the face of a severe pandemic it
could collapse
with no options left most rely on the
private sector
where costs are rising an illness
can push a family into poverty
at a time when the pandemic is raging
doctors and medical staff at this
government hospital in ranchi
are protesting for better protective
gear and facilities
across the country over 100 doctors and
scores of medical staff
have died treating patients testing
is the only way to fight the virus and
halt its spread
though the government has ramped it up
india has one of the lowest testing
numbers
in proportion to its population moreover
the government has failed to prepare
itself adequately during the months of
severe lockdown
its strategy now is in disarray never
lazarus
sky news delhi